hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
special edition of modeling the Masters
today we're going to look at my favorite
five gud seats entrepreneur launches of
all time these are from entrepreneurs
who knew how to get people talking as
soon as their parks came out I hope you
find us so it's inspirational and can
apply some of their lessons into your
business here we go gutsy is
entrepreneur launch number five Deena
white saves the UFC Dana White is the
current president of the Ultimate
Fighting Championship white began
managing MMA fighters Tito Ortiz and
Chuck Liddell before taking over the UFC
this current net worth is 150 million
dollars after purchasing the UFC Dana
White and his partners accumulated over
30 million dollars in losses trying to
make the business viable in the last
ditch effort to save the business white
launched a reality television show The
Ultimate Fighter the future
up-and-coming fighters who is unable to
convince any network to hear the show
until spike TV agreed with one major
condition the UFC would have to pay the
entire 10 million dollar production
costs to create the show white agreed I
would his business on the line the show
became a huge success which ended with
force riffin and Stephan Bonnar fighting
for a six-figure contract white credits
the show for saving the UFC and
continued airing new seasons of The
Ultimate Fighter to expand the awareness
and popularity of his company guts his
entrepreneur launch number four Philip
night science Michael Jordan Philip
night is the co-founder and chairman of
Nike as of two thousand ten nights taken
nike gives him an estimated net worth of
twelve point seven billion dollars
making him the 58th richest person in
the world
in 1985 night launched a new shoe called
air jordan after signing a young
up-and-coming basketball player named
michael jordan to a sponsorship deal the
initial deal was for 2.5 million dollars
over five years an expensive deal at the
time that changed the face of sports
marketing the air Joyner was then banged
by the NBA because his black and red
colors didn't fit with an NBA guidelines
Jordan continued wearing them and was
fined five thousand dollars per game
which Nike paid the air jordan became
the most valuable footwear franchise
thankies history it was so popular that
launch dates had to be postponed to
weekends so kids wouldn't be tempted to
skip school to get their hands on the
latest air jordan the move took nike
from being a running shoe company with
no exposure to the basketball market to
now owning as much as eighty five
percent of the basketball shoe market
you
gutsiest entrepreneur launch number
three Bill Gates pitches a product that
doesn't exist Bill Gates is a chairman
of Microsoft the software company he
founded with Paul Allen he is
consistently ranked among the world's
wealthiest people and was the wealthiest
overall from 1995 to 2009 excluding 2008
where he was ranked third his current
net worth is 56 billion dollars Bill
Gates a longtime friend Paul Allen
turned their passion for programming
into a business when they saw a picture
of the all tear dat on the cover of
popular electronics gates called myths
the company that was manufacturing the
health care and told them that he and
Alan had developed the programming
language for the computer that was ready
to launch not a single line of code
written and no alterative work on gates
and Allen worked around the clock on
Harvard computers to do what they said
they already had done eight weeks later
Allen flute emits headquarters in New
Mexico to present their code without
given a test run the program was a
success and midst bought the rights
making it an industry standard within
one year Gates had dropped out of
Harvard and the two high school friends
established microsoft corporation
gud sees entrepreneur launch number two
Richard Branson drives a tank into Times
Square Sir Richard Branson is a British
entrepreneur best known for his virgin
group of over 400 companies Richard
Branson is a 212 richest person in the
world according to Forbes 2010 list of
billionaires was an estimated net worth
of approximately four billion dollars to
launch virgin Cola he wrote in The Times
Square in New York City on top of a tank
promising a battle with coke and pepsi
to launch Virgin Mobile in Canada he
repelled into the heart of yonge-dundas
square Branson has also made several
world record-breaking attempts with
Virgin Atlantic challenger and Virgin
Atlantic challenger 2 he raced to have
the facets atlantic ocean crossing in
Virgin Atlantic flyer created the
world's largest hot air balloon and was
the first to cross the Atlantic in a
balloon he then tried to become the
first person to go around the world in a
hot air balloon Branson is always
thinking of new ways to launch and
promote his businesses the more
high-profile the better even when it's
done don't work out they garner so much
attention for his business that it's all
worth it
guts his entrepreneur launch number one
PT Barnum puts on a show PT Barnum was
an American showman businessman in
entertainment he was the founder of the
circus that became the Ringling Brothers
and Barnum & Bailey Circus the show was
called the greatest show on earth and
he's my top pick for this list of the
gutsiest entrepreneur launches of all
time even if you didn't have a ticket to
his show when Barnum circus was in town
you wouldn't know it he would sweep into
the city with custom elephants would be
paraded through the streets clowns would
be sent to local hospitals to visit with
sick children Barnum provided a pre-show
to his circus that he hoped would get
people talking and raise excitement
about his show he would give tours of
his circus to anyone who wanted to see
inside the big top and also put on
multiple free contests in order to
attract crowds to his shows Barnum was
always thinking of ways to promote both
himself and his business from making
splashy entrances to using
cross-promotion Barnum did what it took
to make sure people knew who he was
thank you for joining me for this
special edition of all of the Masters I
hope you enjoyed if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear thoughts and feedback if you
want to leave a comment below and stay
tuned for the next episode